thanks for joining us i'm denise valdez
and i'm brian loftis a business owner
jumps into action to confront burglars
breaking into his auto body shop and
tonight he's right back where it
happened promising to protect his
customers cars victoria saha joins us
live outside the body shop with his
story tonight
[Music]
yeah here at universal motor cars there
are dozens of vehicles that customers
left in the hands of the owner victor
batnari but that wasn't going to have
them break their trust when a burglar
found an opening between the barbed
wires and a wall and climbed over
with the alarms with the lights they
were still in the in my property two men
seen in this surveillance video climbed
over a wall in the middle of the night
and started searching through cars but
nari sleeping in a shop after a late
night of work was woken up by the sounds
of the alarms and sprung into action i
decided i have to protect my my business
with just a bat in his hand he
confronted them
i approached them and asked if he took
something please put it back and you
guys are free to go
he didn't hesitate he got something in
his hand he throw me and turn around and
jump the wall and left he put his
dedication to his customers cars first
before his own safety my shop it's my
my business it's my life
i'm realizing now that probably i did a
mistake if they had a gun something
happened to me but at that point i
didn't have no fear michael johnston a
security expert says burglars will
continue to take their chances with the
slightest opening if there is a high
dollar item that's at that business
they may take a greater risk
despite the
uses of alarms or other deterrents you
want to have a system in place that
prevents the entry from the beginning
but nari says he will now make sure his
whole property has a barbed wire fence
around it
johnson's team does security screenings
for businesses to show them the best way
to protect themselves as for bonari he
tells me that he's going to continue
sleeping here until he hires a guard to
watch over this place at night reporting
live tonight victoria saha live local
now